turning now to the fight against the
coronavirus so far about 12 percent of
the u.s population has been fully
vaccinated
meanwhile a coveted vaccine that is not
yet authorized in the u.s the
astrazeneca version
is on hold in more than a dozen european
countries
amid concerns over blood clots cbs news
medical contributor dr david agus joins
us now david good morning
the world health organization says the
benefits of the astrazeneca vaccine
outweigh the potential risks but how
concerned should we be
i i don't think there's any real concern
at the present time there have been tens
of millions of doses of astrazeneca
vaccine to minister throughout europe in
the united kingdom
and a total of 37 blood clots in the leg
in the lung
and when look at those cases and i've
personally reviewed some of them there's
no real evidence that it's connected to
the vaccine at all
and you expect there in that size of a
population to be even more blood clots
again unrelated to the vaccine i think
this is more political than anything
so you don't think the pause in
vaccinations in europe is justified
no i think that you had a couple of
countries who jumped on board
aggressively and did it and part of it
was there's less is of a supply of that
vaccine than they expected and it wasn't
delivered and then every other country
had to say listen if they're doing it
then we're going to have to do it
you had the world health organization
and the european medicine
association which is their equivalent of
the fda say
we're not that concerned about this
either in the united kingdom where
they've administered 12 million doses
they haven't seen this at all
in the randomized clinical trials we
haven't seen this at all
the united states data hopefully will be
announced this week and we'll see if
there's any indication in that data
is is our data entirely separate from
theirs i mean why hasn't it been
authorized in the us yet
anthony that's a great question um we
are requiring that the trial be done
here and so we did not
accept that the data from other
countries for our filing
that data should be hopefully announced
this week looking at the safety and the
efficacy
of this particular vaccine in our
population and we have tens of millions
of doses
ready in refrigerators to be distributed
here in the united states
dr agus we're also talking about moderna
being tested on
children you've pointed out that testing
with children on vaccine safety is
different than adults how so
well in adults we needed to do very long
studies to make sure that it actually
protected us from the virus
now that we know these vaccine works and
children they're very short studies to
look at
safety and if it's the right dose to
give an immune response so we can
measure immune response in the blood
and make sure there are no side effects
and then this vaccine should be rolled
out in children of different ages
what potential warning signs should
researchers be looking for in children
well i think the key question is there's
no question they're going to make a good
immune response is what dose is required
and sometimes
as the frame gets smaller children are
little they may require less of a
vaccine to get an equivalent immune
response
and that's what we're going to find out
you know over the next several months
and then we have to start vaccinating
kids
they are 25 the under 21 age of the u.s
population
yeah it is indeed true children are
little but they are pretty heavy when
you have to carry them block after block
walk on her own i have no idea please
come on honey can you do it let's go
dr david agus thank you very much we
appreciate it